Yeah,
Paul Haggis is a wonderful writer.
Uh,
uh,
Akiva Goldsman is another one,
a doctorate at Pixar,
but I don't really have favorites and
um,
it's not like rock and roll,
it just isn't where you can pick a
favorite and,
and,
and see that they're doing something
really innovative in music and it comes
out,
you know,
every six months there's a song or album
or whatever.
It's not like that because the time
between starting up a screenplay or a
novel or a play and actually seeing it
on stage page or screen is years of,
of uh,
of development and work and it goes on.
I'm over long periods of time.
And so it's not.
There was,
there was a time back when,
50,
60 years ago when screenwriters were
under contract to studios and they were
turning out three,
four,
five screenplays a year
and directors redirecting a two and
three,
four films a year.
Michael Critias,
who directed Casa Blanca by the time he
died,
had directed a hundred and 20 films.
Well,
those days are gone.
If a director gets to direct 12 films in
his lifetime,
you'd be a success,
and so you can't,
you can't trace development and who's
doing the cutting edge thing or whatever
like that.
I'm in it quite in those,
in those ways.
I think the three guys who write produce
and often direct damages,
uh,
the,
the two brothers,
allman brothers and Kessler,
those three guys are,
as doing as exciting,
uh,
work as writers,
as anybody in film.
Film is a very,
would film,
is very conservative.
They do not take risks.
Television is experimental.
I mean watching the Sopranos,
whatever you and we're six feet under,
it was,
uh,
an example of applying to television,
the principle of the novel known as the
unreliable narrator.
You can never be sure when you're
watching the sopranos and six feet
under,
is this a dream sequence?
Is Somebody hallucinating?
This just actually happened or they just
having fun with us.
There's whatever.
I mean,
until you saw enough of the episode,
realize that the whole damned episode
was a dream.
Nobody does that film.
You can't do that in the movies.
You know,
it,
it costs 30 slash 5,000 million dollars
to make a film.
You can't have,
you can't have that kind of an
experimentation.
And when it comes along,
it went.
When such experiments happen,
like,
um,
uh,
the usual suspects when somebody pulls
the plug at the end and you realize
Kevin Spacey made the whole damn thing
up.
It's,
it's,
um,
uh,
a big,
it's a form of cheap surprise.
It's a big,
huge,
cheap surprise.
It's not as if it was being done like
Louis Barnwell would have done in the
sixties to really express the absurdity
of life when,
when,
when film does tricky storytelling,
things like that on occasion,
um,
it's,
it's not as if it's driven by a theme.
It's,
um,
you know,
the,
the six ads for example,
and the mind fuck ending is just cheap
surprise is what film students do,
but it's not as if that filmmaker has a
deep philosophical understanding,
a that runs against the grain of,
of,
of contemporary,
a sense of reality.
I mean,
he's not,
he's just having fun and I'm so he just
does this film school thing,
the mind fuck or whatever.
Uh,
so and so film is very conservative in
that way.
You can't,
can't experiment like that or if it's an
independent film,
you could do films like Pie,
no Aronofsky film,
right?
Which is extremely experimental for the
sake of experimental.
And these guys all went to film school
and,
um,
they were taught barnwell and truffaut
and um,
and the wash and uh,
and uh,
uh,
Bergman and they went,
they were taught the classics of the
Avant Garde.
And so they imitate what used to be
really dangerous stuff in the sixties.
Um,
and it's,
uh,
today,
there's no,
um,
uh,
avant garde today.
It's a retro God.
Today we have people going back to
imitating,
um,
uh,
eccentric forms of the past,
um,
because they went to film school and
they think they should do that and that
makes them an artist.
And so I,
I would say that as a storytelling
medium film in particular has had a dead
end.
There's,
it's,
as I said,
it's very expensive.
It's very conservative and
experimentation is,
um,
is there,
uh,
to have more show off than meaningful
gimmickry.
Um,
it's,
um,
it's something.
Something's got to give on what the hell
that will be a in order for film to
revive itself as an art form,
as a form of entertainment in the form
of commerce,
uh,
films doing than ever.
Oh,
that's such an,
um,
you know,
generally unhappy topic
I've sold or optioned or been our role
written for hire a 12 screenplays in
Hollywood.
Uh,
one of them I have option to four times
over.
And as far as,
uh,
all of my screenplays are concerned.
Um,
none of them ever get produced a,
they have all floundered for various
reasons to no less than three times.
I've had studios change administrations
in the middle of the development of
mine.
Um,
and so,
you know,
when a new a new presidents come in,
they throw out everything that's in
development from the previous
administration and the egos.
I mean,
so one of those sad,
I'm a development hell stories,
uh,
where you know,
you,
you make money.
I mean,
I make,
I made a lot of money,
uh,
but you don't see it on the screen.
On the other hand,
everything I've written for television
gets made and shoveled a lot of episodic
cop shows.
I watched the pilot for the Turner Bible
mini series.
I wrote to Abraham with the director by
Joseph Sergeant,
who's a wonderful Emmy award winning
director.
It started Richard Harrison,
Barbara Hershey and Maximilian Shell.
It was,
you know,
find production.
And so when you write,
when I've written for TV,
they get made and uh,
and they hold up there,
it's good writing.
Um,
but uh,
screenplays a is the guild wants,
did a study of how many of all these
screenplays that get optioned a how many
actually see it to the screen.
A four out of every 20 scripts for which
serious money is paid,
one gets made.
So the age of 20 to one.
So I've,
you know,
I've only right now it's only 12 to one
for me.
So,
so,
you know,
um,
but that's,
that's neither here nor there.
I mean,
that's just the way it is.
And uh,
uh,
just bad luck.
But in the meantime,
while I was going through that period,
um,
I started to teach a writing about
writing and writing about writing
many of them every time one of my
writers wins an Oscar,
a booker prize,
Apulia surprise and Emmy and whatever.
I mean,
when,
when or they call me and um,
and they,
they tell me that,
that they,
they got something published that was
unpublishable and then they came to my
class,
did a rewrite and now it's,
you know,
it's in the world whether they win
awards or not.
But when,
um,
when people take what I teach them,
think it through it all I try to do.
I cannot teach people how to write.
Nobody can teach how to do anything like
that.
I just give them things to think about.
I just want them to think the,
I am categorically opposed to what I
call the Vesuvius School of writing
where it's all magma,
that the writer just sits there and it
just explodes out of them.
And it's sort of like automatic writing
and they just know.
They just,
um,
there are subconscious mind just
whatever that,
that this ridiculous way of teaching
creative writing that there's no craft,
that there's no thought,
that there's no rewriting,
that there's no understanding by the
writer that it's all,
some sort of innocent,
spontaneous that is such idiocy.
Um,
and so,
um,
I can't teach people how to write,
but if I can give them things to think
about things to consider,
uh,
elements of craft and um,
and um,
and,
and the process so that their work
improves and talented people think about
what they're doing at some point in a
way that is very useful to them as a
result of that.
I put the idea in their head that these
are things that can be thought about.
And,
uh,
and here's a way to think about it,
doesn't give you the answers.
It just raises the right questions.
If I can get writers to ask the right
questions of their own work and
financers based upon insights that
they've gained from my writing,
my lecturing,
then,
uh,
my,
my day is made.
Yeah.